ghost lights album number seven by a
Fantasia cease to be a summit and his
supergroup relying on their trademark
brand of music power metal with an
operatic touch they see people running
on their hamster wheels and they don't
know where they're going or why I wanted
to write a fairy tale concept album
about that at the end of February to be
a summit we'll be taking his single
mystery of a blood-red rose into the
German national final for the Eurovision
Song Contest
I spot aeneas Lee said yes it's good
publicity because this kind of musics
hardly mainstream especially not in the
21st century I thought on our world
tours we might reach a couple of hundred
thousand in a few months but there will
reach a few million in three minutes
sure I'll do it it won't be the first
time hard-hitting meadow has made
Eurovision in 2006 called shock rockers
lawdy from Finland finished first now
the song contest is more popular than
ever
just making the qualifying round is a
win for to be a summit when I give an
interview in the United States Britain
or Stockholm everyone asks me about it
to be a summit started out in the early
1990s with EDI at the time still a high
school band to this day they tour almost
every continent to great acclaim here
performing in Brazil
they've brought out ten studio albums
the most recent in 2014 in a good dozen
countries space police defenders of the
crown has raided the charts but in
Germany their fame is mostly limited to
metal fans pretty much everywhere we fly
under the radar but we do have lots of
fans and that's the good part it's much
better than if everybody knows you but
you don't have any fans a woman kind of
headphones Avant Asia's lineup over the
years has included members of KISS the
scorpions and other big name bands to be
a summit started the all-star metal
project in 2000's
sumit also does world tours with aven't
asia they've played back in open air
several times summit describes himself
as a musica holic
just like anyone else I need a hobby
to power down where others might go and
work on that model railways to clear
their minds I go down to the basement to
come up with more music
sumit will soon be taking advantages new
ghost lights album on tour in Europe
Japan and North and South America with
many old friends on the bill this is my
10th world tour and we generally have
the same people along you go through a
lot and it brings you together you can
rely on them and they know they can rely
on you I'm still a bit old school to be
a summit we'll be taking a break from
touring in May to get ready for the
Eurovision Song Contest finals on May
14th and Stockholm but first he'll have
to get through that national final